bonjour bienvenue à l'espace des arts de
chalon sur saône pour un nouveau débat
des élections municipales en direct sur
france 3 bourgogne
tous les invités nous attendent là haut
sur le plateau il est temps de commencer
nous continuons donc notre série de
débats dans les grandes villes de
bourgogne nous sommes ce matin à chalon
sur saône mallard tombe de l'espace des
arts un lieu emblématique de la ville en
partenariat avec le journal de saône et
loire pour un débat avec les quatre
candidats le maire socialiste de la
ville christophe sirugue bonjour bonjour
pour la droite gilles platret bonjour à
vous bonjour pascal dufresne y est le
candidat du tout vrillière bonjour
pascal dufresne y est j ghislaine launay
part dans la tête de liste du front
national bonjour à vous et merci à tous
les quatre d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et chez vous vous pouvez
réagir à ce débat vos réactions
passeront à l'antenne sur notre site
internet et sur le réseau twitter avec
le hashtag diesel vm bourgogne et diez
f3 bourgogne nous allons aborder avec
benoit montaggioni mon camarade du
journal de saône et loire un certain
nombre de points précis de la vie de
chalon sur saône qui sont au coeur de la
campagne
nous allons aussi parler politique avec
le contexte national mais d'abord la
ville elle-même chalon sur saône
deuxième ville de bourgogne dites nous
comment vous la voyez ce que vous aimez
ce qui ne vous plaît pas en commençant
par le maire christophe sirugue tout
d'abord bienvenue bienvenue dans cette
retombe de l'espace des arts c'est un
haut lieu de la vie culturelle
chalonnaise qui participe de son
rayonnement le rayonnement de cette
ville c'est sale éléments qui me paraît
le plus important
première ville du département deuxième
bassin économique de la région bourgogne
en même temps une ville avec un cadre de
vie assez exceptionnel des atouts
extraordinaires en termes de
positionnement est une ville qui sait
dialoguer avec celles et ceux qui
l'entourent
une ville qu'il joue un rôle moteur et
donc lorsque l'on est à chalon sur saône
on est d'abord dans une ville qui compte
qu'ils comptent en saône et loire qui
compte en bourgogne est une ville qui
entend bien continuer à un peu se
positionner sur ces enjeux là gilles
platret votre votre vision de la vie
c'est une ville qui a un atout majeur
c'est la vitalité de ses habitants
lorsqu'on regarde la somme des
initiatives qui souhaitent être prises
ici dans les associations dans le monde
sportif
dans le monde économique particulier le
monde commerçant on se rend compte qu'on
a tout pour faire mais aujourd'hui
chalon est confronté aussi à des soucis
majeurs à des verrous qu'il s'agit
peut-être de faire sauter dans cette
élection qui bride les initiatives qui
empêche de libérer
les énergies et c'est tout l'enjeu de ce
qui arrive aujourd'hui de cette grande
échéance démocratique qui s'annonce dans
quinze jours c'est faire en sorte que
nous soyons en mesure d'offrir le moyen
de libérer les énergies des chalonnais
pascal dufrègne bonjour oui je crois que
oui pas tout à fait dans la même ville
moi ça fait deux mois que je fais
campagne dans les quartiers populaires
de chalon est ce que profondément jure
sens un vrai ras-le-bol de cette crise
assez les choses ont empiré depuis la
dernière élection municipale ya six ans
vous était candidate ou j'étais déjà
candidat et le chômage continuer à faire
de plus en plus d'un mètre de plus en
plus de travailleurs au chauffeur est
dans la misère et d'un côté ya ce
gouvernement socialiste qui est élu
depuis deux ans et je ressentis à vrai
que rement parmi les travailleurs que
j'ai rencontrés dans les quartiers de
setques en deux sets de ce gouvernement
parce qu'en réalité ce qu'on s'aperçoit
sait qu'il est dans le camp des patrons
et moi fut vraiment quand on voit tous
les gens qui sont dans le camp des
bourgeois c'est à dire de ces grandes
entreprises qui vont voir le
gouvernement pour demander des milliards
et ben e
ils se font entendre du gouvernement et
ben moi je pense et c'est le sens de ma
présence de notre candidature dans les
municipales c'est de faire entendre le
camp des travailleurs
on va y venir en particulier sur les sur
les entreprises qui viennent donner
votre vision de la ville eh bien je suis
surprise d'entendre une vision aussi
idyllique de chalon sur saône c'est vrai
que sous le ciel bleu avec un beau
soleil mais il faut voir dans les
coulisses ce qui se passe et au niveau 2
du bilan de la ville au niveau comptable
les difficultés continuent à s'accumuler
il me semble et on essaye de maquiller
les chiffres en transportant sur le
grand chalon les difficultés que connaît
la ville
mais l'avenir n'est pas si rose que que
ce que les deux candidats principaux
peuvent nous présenter on notera quand
même que gilles platret ne l'avait pas
des quais forcément si rose que ça une
réponse christophe sirugue gpat raid il
faut libérer des énergies ce qui
voudrait dire qu'elles ne le sont pas je
crois que on a la chance en essayent
d'avoir cette dynamique mais c'est
dynamique elle n'est possible que si
elle est soutenue
or en même temps depuis des années
d'ailleurs est encore au cours des six
années qui viennent de s'écouler
la participation qu'il ya pu y avoir
entre le tissu associatif le tissu
sportif le tissu culturel et la
municipalité a été particulièrement
marqué nous avons inauguré il ya
quelques mois de cela la maison des
associations avec une foule immense à
cette occasion là elle était je crois la
meilleure démonstration de ce
partenariat que nous avons un carnet au
cours de ces six années gilles platret
vous êtes et vous aussi candidat la
dernière fois mais c'était une mandature
de droite qui qui est elle a
précédemment
quel diagnostic vous faites quand vous
avez des libérer les énergies en
précisant un petit peu ce serait quoi la
question n'est pas de savoir si c'est
une mandature de droite ou de gauche
la question c'est de savoir si on veut
pour les chalonnais mener une politique
qui favorise l'expansion de la question
de savoir si votre position avait changé
bien sûr on est aujourd'hui sur le bilan
puisque nous sommes au terme d'un mandat
il faut bien que nous parlions du bilan
et ce bilan ne nous paraît pas
favorables parce que ce n'est pas le
souhait de passer l'émission entière sur
le bilan de monsieur sirugue les
chalonnais sont en capacité de s'en
faire une idée et d'ailleurs il nous en
parle régulièrement qu'on nous les
rencontrons puisque nous avons lancé
depuis six ans et puis avec une
accélération évidemment depuis six mois
une grande consultation pour saisir
véritablement ce que pensent les gens
et que pensent les chalonnais
aujourd'hui il pense que cette ville
qu'ils aiment profondément comme nous
l'aimons tous que cette ville
elle est aujourd'hui bloquée sur le plan
de la circulation que cette ville elle
perd des emplois quotidiennement et je
n'oublie pas bien entendu je n'oublie
pas celles et ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
plongés dans le chômage pense il n'y a
pas une seule famille de chalon sur
saône qui ne soit pas directement ou
indirectement plongée est concerné par
le chômage
brooks et quand je parle de libérer les
énergies c'est de partir de cette idée
que les chalonnais veulent agir mais
qu'il faut pour cela changer la
politique qu'il aurait proposé on va
avancer un petit peu il ya eu un constat
et de diagnostic on va dire et puis vous
allez nous proposez vous remède dylan
launay pour vous comme un candidat à la
présidence l'avait fait - président vous
maire de chalon vous changer quoi la
fiscalité
arrêtez de arrêter de penser qu'on ne
peut faire quelque chose dans une ville
qu avec de l'argent et en augmentant les
impôts de ceux qui vivent et qui
travaillent sur place
tout tout tout les initiatives que vous
proposez demande de l'argent en
permanence et en permanence où il faut
rajouter au pot là les taxes foncières
augmenté de 25% en quatre ans c'est
c'est insupportable ce qui implique que
vous limitez aussi les investissements
de la ville ou le développement de la
ville qu'est ce que ça veut dire les
années des investissements qui sont de
la poudre aux yeux dans la mesure où les
chalonnais eux-mêmes vivent de façon
difficile si c'est pour en mettre plein
la vue au reste de la france où se
positionner par rapport à d'autres
villes de même importance
c'est parce que recherchent les
chalonnais pascal dufresne mois écouter
ce que j'ai décrit tout à l'heure sur la
situation des quartiers populaires oui
c'est la crise et je crois que la
bourgeoisie dans notre société n'a pas
de solution ou tout au moins en a une
c'est de la faire payer aux travailleurs
donc que proposez vous et bah écoutez
déjà faut comprendre qu'il n'ya pas de
solution dans le système actuel avec les
solutions actuelles parce que les
solutions actuelles qui ont été employés
par le gouvernement de l'ump sarkozy
hier ou aujourd'hui par françois
hollande c'est d'arroser à coups de
milliards les patrons et tout le monde
sait dans les quartiers populaires où je
suis passé que ces solutions lan abouti
rien a pas enrichir encore un peu plus
les patrons qui eux continuent à
licencier
j'ai écouté j'ai une expérience
personnelle dans cette ville moi je suis
un homme un ancien ouvrier de kodak
j'ai été à chalon photochimie on a été
licencié on est allé voir monsieur
sirugue monsieur patriat est venu nous
voir on a même eu sarkozy qui est passé
nous serrer la main et nous de souhaiter
bonne continuation à moi un an avant
qu'on soit licencié on a rencontré
monsieur montebourg et qui est ce qu il
en est ressorti tout ça est bien du
blabla moi la seule chose que je garde
de cette période c'est les solidarités
ouvrières que j'ai eus avec mes
camarades c'est les luttes qu'on a mené
c'est la fierté qu'on a eu à les mener
et profondément et bien pour l'avenir
pour changer ça je crois que la classe
ouvrière demain refera irruption sur la
scène politique se fera entendre à la
une force incroyable et une force
collective pour imposer des vrais
changements on est d'accord que dans
cette campagne
pascal dufresne les mots d'ordre que
vous portez sont nationaux et généraux
qui a pas de point précis sur la ville
de chalon écoutez les problèmes de
chalon sont les mêmes que de ceux tous
les toutes les villes autour de nous
faut pas se raconter des blagues
il n'y a pas de solution locale à tout
ça il va falloir qu'à un moment donné
les travailleurs et qui profitent de ces
élections pour faire autant le camp des
travailleurs
christophe sirugue vous allez exercer un
premier mandat ce serait quoi
de façon générale dans les grandes
lignes un deuxième mandat je crois que
dans un contexte économique et social
difficile et tout le monde reconnaît
qu'il est difficile à chalon comme
ailleurs le seul moyen de s'en sortir
c'est d'abord de rassembler rassembler
les chalonnais rassembler les forces
économiques rassembler les forces
sociales portées ensemble finalement des
orientations qui répondent aux enjeux
les enjeux d'emplois qui sont développés
sont des vrais enjeux importants perd
personne ne peut penser sérieusement que
c'est le maire qui créent les emplois ou
les supprime mais créer les conditions
du développement économique est un enjeu
important créé les conditions qu'il
fasse que chacun puisse trouver sa place
dans la ville quel que soit son âge
quels que soient ces conditions c'est
aussi un enjeu important celui de
l'école tout particulièrement créer les
conditions des solidarités créer les
conditions du vivre
semble pour les personnes qui
vieillissent pour les personnes qui ont
besoin de cette solidarité bref trouver
les supports qui font que alors qu'on
est dans une période difficile et qui
laissa si bien évidemment de ne prendre
que les aspects négatifs plutôt
privilégier ce qui nous rassemble que ce
qui nous divise
me semblent être les seuls éléments
moteurs qui permettent est bien de faire
que le mandat qui viennent son mandat
qui poursuivent le rayonnement de notre
ville et le rayonnement bien sûr pour
l'ensemble de ses habitants
ça pourrait ressembler ce que vous
disiez g place rapidement oui sauf que
le rassemblement ça doit pas être des
mots ça doit être des actes et on est
bien sur le jourdain bilan et la
projection dans l'avenir
la démarche que nous avons conduite
isabelle de chaume sébastien martins
mois l'ensemble de celles et ceux qui
ont décidé de travailler à nos côtés
pour changer la majorité municipale
c'est une démarche qui d'abord et avant
tout autre considération veut redonner
la parole aux chalonnais c'est à dire
aller vers eux les écouter nous aurons
fait au total 26 réunions de quartier
nous avons multiplié les cafés débats
nous sommes allés en porte à porte il
n'y a pas un seul quartier pas une seule
rue qui n'aura été visitées pour que
nous puissions entendre et le constat
premier que nous faisons c'est qu'à
l'issue des six années qui viennent de
s'écouler
les chalonnais veulent reprendre la
parole ils veulent reprendre la parole
et c'est pourquoi l'un des objectifs
majeurs
on parlera tout à l'heure d'emplois
repart un développement économique
comparé les transports là les objectifs
majeurs c'est que le maire de chalon sur
saône soit un maire à plein temps qui
s'occupe des électeurs et des électrices
et de l'ensemble de la population
parce que le premier travail d'un élu
c'est d'être au service de ceux qui
l'ont nommé il est un peu plus vous nous
avez dit stop à la fiscalité pour vous
il ya d'autres grandes lignes
importantes pour chalon sur saône sont
maintenant tenir le micro
j'écoute les différents intervenants et
je vous avouerai que ce serait assez
proche de monsieur du frais mais mais je
je je je pourrais n'ont pas parlé des
travailleurs simplement mais du
d'élargir un peu le d'élargir un peu les
catégories qui sont qui souffrent et qui
ont besoin d'autre chose qui ont besoin
d'une autre logique
voilà c'est là
je voulais dire c'est élargir c'est à
dire il n'ya pas que les travailleurs il
y a les personnes les personnes âgées il
y a les familles il y à toutes sortes de
toutes sortes de populations et toutes
là toute la population qui habite à
chalon est qui qui n'a pas des
conditions de vie extraordinaire dans
des quartiers protégés travailleurs ou
pas ils souffrent et ont besoin d'autre
chose
une question précise concernant le front
national selon les villes le
positionnement des candidats du front
national n'est pas toujours le même par
rapport aux va dire à ce que sont les
thèmes initiaux du front national
particulier sur l'immigration sur la
préférence nationale qu'elle est vous
sur chalon sur saône votre position sur
ces thèmes-là sur sur ce type de thèmes
qui sont les fondements au départ du
front national préférence nationale
limitation de l'immigration les les
problèmes se posent à chalon comme comme
partout pour le pour le phénomène de
l'immigration
je pense qu'il suffit d'aller dans les
quartiers dans les grandes dans les
grands ensembles pour s'apercevoir qu'il
ya des tours complète qui sont habités
par des personnes qui ne qu'ils savent
pas où elles sont elles sont restés dans
leur tête d'où elles viennent
elle ne parle pas français elles sont là
à être nourris à être logés mais elles
ne sont pas partis des populations qui
peuvent se prendre en main et participer
à la vie chalonnaise
donc c'est un gros problème parce que
c'est un c'est un poids lourd c'est un
poil c'est un poids dans les écoles
c'est un poids dans la vie communale
société pascal dufresne haut niveau je
vous avais envie de réagir à la
proposition de rapprochement tant des
trucs comme ça a coûté c'est méprisant
pour les travailleurs ou à votre
discours vous savez à par diviser les
travailleurs entre les français les
immigrés d'un côté et les travailleurs
français entre les chômeurs les
feignants et ceux qui bossent moi j'en
ai marre parce que c'est officiel je
voudrais pas coupé
donc moi j'en ai marre d'entendre ce
discours là qui n'est que d'une division
des travailleurs et je pense que voter
front national quand on a un ouvrier
bah c'est se tirer une balle dans le
pied parce que vous ne dites pas une
chose c'est que les vrais ennemis des
travailleurs ce qui nous plonge dans la
misère et dans la crise c'est les
patrons et ceux qui les aident à nous
plonger dans cette misère
c'est les politiciens du fn du ps et de
l'ump
vous dénoncez pas ça christophe sirugue
moi j'avais noté ce que disait gilles
platret qui était de donner la
possibilité aux chalonnais de reprendre
la parole
comment est-ce que c'est au cours de ce
mandat que se sont développés les outils
dits de démocratie participative
le conseil des sages le conseil
municipal des jeunes les conseils
consultatifs locaux
les concertations sur les grands projets
j'entends bien qui eux certains font
beaucoup de réunions ce moment pendant
six ans combien de réunions dans les
quartiers
aucune aucune donc à un moment c'est
bien de venir au moment de la période
électorale mais je pense qu'il faut de
ce point de vue rappeler qu'il y a un
travail régulier en tout cas pour ce qui
me concerne tous les ans je suis
retourné rendre compte du bilan de
l'action municipale dans les quartiers
je vais revenir si mon mac arrêté sur
deux choses premièrement la question de
l'équilibré démographique
chalon est une ville qui est
démographiquement équilibré et le
paysage que nous décrit madame launay
sans doute une vue depuis la guiche mais
pas une vie depuis chalon sur saône
cela étant l'endroit vous habitez madame
cela étant ce que je voudrais dire il ya
des rumeurs qui circulent on aurait
passé des accords pour que 300 familles
de roms au cours d une fois ce sont des
roms la gloire du 9-3 et on l'a on a eu
tort et on la trouve partout en france
merci de le reconnaître je voulais en
profiter pour démentir certaines
nouvelles choses et au début si vous me
le permettez je viens d'entendre
monsieur platret nous dire qu'on allait
débattre du développement économique
qu'on allait débattre des transports
j'espère qu'il n'a pas oublié que ce
sont des compétences du grand chalon il
nous explique dans le même temps qu'il
veut être à 100% maire de chalon mais il
nous explique qu'on va débattre alors
qu'il en a fait aucune proposition de
sujets qui relèvent du grand chalon
j'attends avec beaucoup d'intérêt de
voir comment cela peut se concrétiser
puisque aucun projet sur le grand chalon
n'a été portée par le candidat plâtre on
a prévu de parler du grand chalon si on
en a le temps une réponse des plats très
bien sûr avant de passer à des thèmes
précis que vous avez évoqué puisque vous
nous avez déjà fait le programme
c'est pas tant une réponse qu'un constat
quand on nous dit que nous n'avons pas
fait de réunions de quartier et que dans
le même temps la personne qui nous dit
ça a passé plus de la moitié de son
temps en dehors de sa ville pendant six
ans a exercé des mandats certes très
honorable mais qui l'aurait éloigné de
la réalité du terrain
je pense qu'il ya là
un fossé qui n'est pas conforme à la
vérité d'autre part sur la question du
développement économique et des
transports nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
une échéance où on se positionne à la
fois pour des compétences qui sont les
compétences demeurer à la ville et
d'autres qui sont les compétences du
grand chalon ne pas vouloir exercer
comme c'est mon cas le cumul de tous les
mandats ne pas vouloir concentrer sur ma
personne tous les pouvoirs à la ville à
l'agglomération et ailleurs ça ne veut
évidemment pas dire que le maire de
chalon sur saône que je serai se
désintéressera de ces questions et bien
au contraire nous les avons mises au
coeur de notre campagne et c'est bien
pourquoi il faut aujourd'hui répondre je
sais bien que c'est pas très plaisant
pour le maire sortant je veux parler de
développement économique et de transport
puisque ce sont deux des gros points
noirs dans ses mandats mais néanmoins
dans parlera dans le cours de l'émission
sur me permettez une remarque j'ai
interrogé depuis des semaines sur le
projet que vous portiez pour le grand
chalon j'ai interrogé depuis des
semaines sur les responsabilités qui
serait réparti je vous ai entendu dire
dans un premier temps que le président
du grand chalon serait le maire d'une
petite commune
j'ai lu ce matin dans la presse que vous
expliquez que vous vous répartition
entre les trois puisque vous avez
tellement mal à vous faire confiance que
vous êtes obligé les trois partout que
vous répartis par thiriez les rôles
entre vous dites aux chalonnais dit
qu'ils assument quelles responsabilités
dit quels projets vous portez pour le
grand chalon vous ne pouvez pas en même
temps dire je ne peux pas parler du
grand chalon comme vous l'avez fait dans
la presse en disant parce que je ne sais
pas quelle sera la majorité donc on veut
pas s'engager avant mais nous nous avons
travaillé avec l'ensemble des équipes
qui partagent notre sensibilité dans le
grand chalon
sauf que vous n'arrivez pas à travailler
que les autres c'est ça la difficulté qu
est la vôtre vous n'arrivez pas
travailler autant que vous allez
commencer je vous propose avant qu'on
rentre sur les thèmes concrets qu'on
avait prévu d'aborder qu'on continue sur
l'intercommunalité parce que je crois
que c'est commencer et on sait que c'est
un des nouveautés de ce scrutin puisque
les gens vont voter aussi pour la
première fois avec un vrai fléchage pour
les représentants l'agglomération on se
souvient que chalon sur saône ça a été
un point chaud sur les intercommunalités
puisque le fonctionnement était un petit
peu chaotique à une époque avec un choix
très particulier
du maire de la ville qui lui n'était pas
président de l'agglomération avec des
relations un petit peu compliqué donc ma
question est pour vous d'abord j'ai le
plâtre est effectivement est-ce que vous
quels choix vous ferez si vous êtes élu
maire de chalon celui de faire comme
dans beaucoup de grandes villes où le
maire de la ville est aussi président de
l'agglomération
parce qu'on sait aujourd'hui qu'il ya
beaucoup de compétences qui sont au
niveau de l'agglo ou est ce que vous
ferez un autre choix comme ça a été fait
dans le temps je me les je me permets
juste de rectifier une partie de votre
propos aujourd'hui en france 47% des
agglomérations ne sont pas présidé par
lé maire de la ville centre
j'aurais dû dire de bourgogne regardez
alors regardez ce qui se passe en
saône-et-loire à mâcon
la communauté d'agglomération n'est pas
présidé par je perdrais a fait remarquer
que la camval est en guerre civile
depuis un certain nombre d'années la
communauté communauté urbaine si chère
au coeur de monsieur sirugue n'est pas
présidé par le maire de montceau où le
maire du creusot et je veux je crois
sincèrement parce qu'on est aussi un
tournant démocratique dans cette
élection regardons ce qui se passe à
chalon mais regardons ce qui se passe
aussi dans le reste de la france la
concentration des pouvoirs s'est
terminée à l'établissement public de
coopération intercommunale puisqu'on
parle du grand chalon ce n'est pas un
établissement public de concentration de
pouvoirs et aujourd'hui comment pouvoir
dire lorsqu'on est à la tête d'une liste
à chalon sur saône
je serai le président du grand chalon
mais on a oublié que dans cette
intercommunalité est ce que vous en
auriez envie est ce que vous pensez que
ce serait plus efficace non je ne le
pense pas parce que le partage du
pouvoir l'entendre sur un projet de
territoire est nécessaire mais pour
qu'il y ait entente il faut pas
échafauder des plans de sensibilité
politique j'ai entendu le terme de
sensibilité politique il faut qu'il y
ait un accord sur un projet de
territoire
cet accord n'existe plus aujourd'hui ils
n'existent plus parce que dès qu'un
maire d'une commune d'une taille
inférieure chez en sursaut n'a voulu
émettre une opinion divergente dans le
cours de ce mandat il a été sabré le
maire de l'ue qui était vice-président
du grand chalon a osé dans son conseil
municipal voté contre une augmentation
du prix de l'eau imposé par le grand
chalon
on peut penser ce qu'on veut du fond du
vote mais on respecte le vote que s'est
il passé dans la semaine qui a suivi
monsieur sirugue la démissionné de ses
fonctions de vice président est-ce que
c'est ainsi qu'on établit la confiance
entre inconnus en tout cas ça n'est
évidemment pas comme ça vous l'aurez
compris qu'on va aborder les choses
on va faire répondre les sauf si rude
parce qu'il ya un côté cocasse que ce
soit monsieur platret qui me parle du
rassemblement je rappelle que monsieur
platret a été élu à saint désert
ses amis lui ont demandé de quitter ses
fonctions je rappelle que monsieur
platret a été président du pays du
chalonnais
ses amis lui ont demandé de quitter ses
fonctions je rappelle que monsieur
platret a été membre de la communauté
d'agglomération ses amis lui ont demandé
de quitter ses fonctions se rappelle de
la lettre extraordinaire qu'il avait
rédigée à cette époque il a été membre
de l'ump
on lui a demandé de bien vouloir sortir
de l'ump il sonne tellement dans le trio
qu'ils ont constitué que j'ai là les
articles de presse qui étaient diffusés
notamment par monsieur guide sur ce
qu'il pensait de monsieur platret et il
vient se présenter comme celui qui peut
rassembler
je constate pour moi que en effet si
j'ai des mandats c'est un moment parce
que les électeurs me les ont confiés
moi je pense que je ne vois pas qui à
part les rochers love le confier au
grand chelem n'est pas un bandage
braqueurs ouais mais très dur quand même
beaucoup de tension composeront chalot
sur le grand chalon j'ai été élu avec un
nombre de voix bien supérieures à ce
qu'elles équilibrent politique
habituelle et vous le savez très bien et
même mieux que cela
si aujourd'hui j'assume les fonctions au
niveau du pays du chalonnais
c'est à la demande des présidents des
communautés de communes qui tous sauf un
sont de la sensibilité politique qui est
la vôtre donc s'il y en a un qui peut
parler du rassemblement s'il y en a un
qui travaillent au rapprochement avec la
communauté urbaine s'il y en a un qui
travaillent au rapprochement avec le
grand dijon parce que nous avons une
métropole lyonnaise qui est en train de
se constituer parce que nous avons le
grand paris qui est en train de se
constituer qu'il faut que l'on se
structure c'est bien moi tout votre
parcours a été un parcours qui a montré
que vous ne pouviez pas travailler avec
les autres vous êtes mal placés pour
donner ce genre de son vrai nom mettrait
à l'horizon si l'on veut se lancer dans
le petit jeu des petites phrases je
rappellerai les relations extrêmement
idyllique que vous avez qu'un certain
nombre des membres de votre parti
politique et en particulier votre
successeur à la tête du conseil général
de saône et loire qui depuis deux mois
10 sur tous les plateaux télé et radio
qu'il a pris un département en quasi
faillite est au bord de la tutelle
donc monsieur sirugue sachez une chose
c'est qu'un homme politique quel qu'il
soit quelles que soient ses opinions
sera jugé sur sa capacité à fédérer
autour de lui ça vous ennuie rina
mention que nous ayons fait un monstre
union avec isabelle de choses c'est à
saint martin ça vous ennuie je le sais
bien puisque c'était le principal
argument que vous ne vous en déplaise
cette union elle est elle est tenace
elle marche sur le terrain et d'ailleurs
les chalonnais ne citerons pas qu'ils
viennent nous voir si nombreux dans nos
réunions a expliqué quelles sont les
responsabilités de chacun vous ne
répondez pas aux questions je vous ai
posé là dessus sur le question du grand
chalon je me suis je suis permet de vous
couper vous êtes présent d'avant sous
les 2 merci de respecter les règles
on a on va avancer pour sur d'autres
thèmes il est nommé pascal dufresne
quand même sur l'intercommunalité c'est
une des nouveautés de ces élections et
c'est une nouveauté et en regardant un
peu de plus près on s'aperçoit que tout
n'ait tout n'est pas réglé mais moi je
me pose la question des compétences et
de chalon et de l'intercommunalité
que reste-t-il au conseil municipal de
chalon comme compétence par rapport au
conseil de la du grand chalon tout ça
est en train de se mettre en place et je
me demande si ces élections que nous
vivons sont vraiment adapté à cette
nouvelle organisation qui est proposé
pour toutes les communautés de communes
je trouve ça très très surprenant qu'est
ce qui vous surprend mais concrètement
parce que de quoi ton responsables au
niveau du conseil municipal ce que nous
allons élire je pense que le maire
pourrait nous le dira mais voilà toutes
les prérogatives sont sont fondues par
rapport aux prérogatives qui ont été
dévolus au grand chalon
donc ça c'est c'est très surprenant je
trouve et on élit sur le grand chalon il
va y avoir 35 élus de chalon le reste
des autres communes toute cette
répartition risque de poser des
problèmes d'entente de vraiment cette
fois la chose ça c'est assez compliqué
pascal dufresne
écoutez moi je sais pas
intercommunalités ou pas moi ce que je
vois c'est que finalement on assiste à
un combat de coqs entre deux candidats
inquiets rentrant l'autre peut-être
sortant je sais pas où l' inverse
mais en tout cas moi je pense que ça a
pas passionné les travailleurs que j'ai
rencontrés dans la campagne parce que en
fait ces débats là où cette politique
que l'état à mener en mettez en place
les communautés d'agglo ça sert agité
tout un petit monde politique mais en
réalité ça sert surtout à cacher
qu'on parle pas des principaux problèmes
des travailleurs et de la guerre qui
leur est menée par les patrons avec leur
complicité
on va les uns et des autres on va parler
entreprises et emploie aussi et c'est le
moment d'accueillir benoit montaggioni
puisque nous sommes sur cette émission
avec nos partenaires du journal de saône
et loire et benoît vient nous rejoindre
pour aborder un certain nombre de thèmes
précis de la campagne alors on a déjà
commencé on avait prévu bonjour benoît
est prévu que par les affaires
communalité ego aussi mais ça a commencé
on a continué on voulait aussi parler
d'un thème qui agitent la la campagne à
chalon les finances les impôts mais on
va parler un peu d'argent puisque le mot
de faillite j'ai entendu tout à l'heure
de ce côté aussi tutelle on l'a entendu
également
on a vu que plusieurs magazines a
récemment qu'ils ont dit que la ville de
chalon avait des problèmes de dettes
notamment et on vous a entendu monsieur
sirugue dire donner un chiffre que vous
avez appelé l'autofinancement moi j'ai
envie d'en prendre un autre la capacité
d'autofinancement nette par habitant 1
on va pas être trop compliqué mais en
gros vaut mieux être positif on est à
moins 25 par habitant à chalon on a à
peu près à 78 pour la moyenne de la
strate
est ce qu'on peut dire dès lors que la
ville de chalon est bien gérée au niveau
financier s capa sk par problèmes de
dette
d'abord rappelé que j'entends ce
discours sur la situation financière
depuis cinq ans j'ai depuis cinq ans
tous les ans les comptes sont validés
par l'état que depuis cinq ans nous
avons eu un rapport de la chambre
régionale des comptes débattu en
novembre 2011 au conseil municipal qui
mentionne les éléments de satisfaction
par rapport au choix pris par la
municipalité qui depuis cinq ans je me
rappelle quand même fonds que les
banques nous prêtent ne faisons pas
partie des collectivités qui ont eu de
mal à lever leurs empreintes puisque
tous les emprunts inscrits au budget ont
été levées à des taux qui sont parmi les
plus bas qu'on n'ait jamais mais non je
ne suis pas d'accord avec ça non non non
le chalon a perdu des habitants non non
non non non je ne suis pas d'accord et
c'est tellement je voudrais d'abord sur
l'autofinancement celui que vous évoquez
négatif j'ai là le rapport de la chambre
régionale des comptes et l'algérie lanta
on est bien d'accord qui dit la chose
suivante la capacité d'autofinancement
nette est également bien inférieure à
celle de la
sur toute la période il parle de 2004 à
2009 là et elle est même négative ou
nulle en 2004 2006 2007 et 2008 c'est à
dire que historiquement depuis de
nombreuses années la capacité
d'autofinancement un net est négatif à
chalon elle était de - 1,85 en 2008 elle
est de -0 99
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas entendu tout au
cours des années précédentes que cet
élément capacité d'autofinancement de
capacité d'autofinancement nette était
mise en cause mais si on intègre les
excédents parce que quand vous faites un
équilibre budgétaire vous intégrez les
excédents et vous savez parfaitement ce
là la situation que j'ai trouvé en 2008
c'était une capacité d'autofinancement à
450000 euros
elle est aujourd'hui à 3 million deux
cent mille euros et je redis que cette
musique qui est finalement lancé par les
uns et par les autres ne correspond pas
à la situation financière de la ville
je redis aussi que si elle était celle
que chacun voudrait bien évoqué au cours
de cette émission alors nous n'aurions
pas pu placer la situation dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons financièrement qui
est aujourd'hui meilleure scène était en
alors la question de la dette monsieur
platret vous là vous l'avez soulevé
régulièrement dans vos réunions
publiques
vous avez aussi vous ne voulez pas
augmenter les impôts comment on peut
s'attaquer à une dette
c'est ce que voulait faire sont toujours
à la fiscalité un mot d'abord sur la
réalité de la situation financière de la
ville
elle est dans un état de dégradation
avancée je vais bien que nous
multiplions les chiffres je veux bien
qu'on ne fasse pas confiance au leader
de l'opposition que j'ai été pendant
quelques années à celui qui aujourd'hui
à la tête d'une liste tous pour chalon
propose une autre politique et notamment
en matière budgétaire mais qu'on regarde
ailleurs les indicateurs qui nous sont
donnés par des personnalités extérieures
des associations locales dont on a mis
en cause le crédit d'une manière
d'ailleurs assez peu respectueuse de la
loi 1901 peu marqués politiquement
elles le sont marqués politiquement
parce qu'elles sont régies par la loi de
1901 consolation de poser
ce sont des associations de
contribuables qui regroupe des gens de
sensibilités différentes qui ont décidé
de travailler sur les cons mais qu'on ne
les croit pas non plus si l'on veut
qu'on regarde simplement les chiffres
quand on vient se prévaloir dans la
première partie du propos de monsieur
sirugue
le rapport de la chambre régionale des
comptes qui date de mai lyon sur la
gestion je l'est aussi ici sur la
gestion qui courait jusqu'en 2009 en
disant que ça va pas si mal que ça
c'était la première partie son propos
après qu'il en ait eu extrait quelque
chose qui l'arrangeait il oublie juste
de dire quelque chose c'est que depuis
l'endettement de la ville a explosé et
celui du grand chalon avec alors
aujourd'hui oui nous avons une capacité
nette d'autofinancement qui est très
dégradé elle est négative de plus d'un
million d'euros
c'est les 25 euros par habitant que vous
citiez dans votre propos de présentation
je vois juste dire et on conteste la
qualité pour les signes l'était pas si
l'on ne l'était pas veut pas nous croire
nous on regarde la presse ne l'était pas
un regarde le journal saône et loire via
trois jours qui se fait écho du journal
les échos qui analyse les 36000 communes
de france si l'on ne nous croit pas
qu'on regarde le magazine capital qui
décerne à monsieur sirugue une veste
rouge en matière de gestion
tout ça ce sont des données qui ne
viennent pas de nous ce sont des
observateurs indépendants donc oui les
finances vont mal
oui nous avons une capacité
d'autofinancement nette négative
oui nous avons un endettement qui a
explosé sur la durée du mandat avec une
fiscalité qui a couru beaucoup trop vite
donc oui nous sommes obligés de jouer
serré dans l'avenir mais vous qui voulez
investir dans la ville comme on fait
alors on avait je ne suis pas le seule
journée merci je suis pas seul dit merci
à vouloir investir car on peut pas
imaginer qu'une ville cesse ses
investissements sauf si sauf si l'état
dégradation des finances devait amener
le préfet à reprendre la main nous
savons très bien
nous savons très bien que l'état par les
autorités préfectorales ont commencé de
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé sur un
certain nombre de dérives et vous savez
pourquoi n'y a pas de hasard
ce sont les mêmes qui de 2004 en 2008
ont mis le département de saône-et-loire
en quasi faillite qui sont aux affaires
à chalon sur saône depuis 2008
les mêmes causes les mêmes personnes ont
produit les mêmes si on va faire répond
que nature un confetti
le nombre d'années et ensuite on fera
désendetter la ville
si on devait rembourser le capital de la
dette aujourd'hui en 2008 ce nombre
d'années était de 14 16 années
aujourd'hui ce nombre d'années et des
9,22 année
donc à un moment je veux bien en effet
qu'on fasse dire ce que l'on veut aux
chiffres
mais pour aller en sens de ce que dit
monsieur platret ce qui m'étonne c'est
puisque vous avez cette analyse de la
ville pourquoi vous n'avez jamais
pendant cinq ans demander aux autorités
administratives de ce pays de faire le
point sur la situation et financière
vous ne l'avez jamais fait tout
simplement parce qu'il n'ya pas les
éléments pour cela et éléments
extraordinaires vous dites la situation
financière de la ville est
catastrophique
vous dites je n'augmenterai pas les
impôts mais vous dites dans votre
document de campagne que vous allez
engager 10 millions d'euros
d'investissements par an c'est à dire
plus que ce que nous mêmes nous allons
mettre en place puisque je me suis
positionné sur 8 millions la droite
d'euros d'investissements par an donc
une chose ou l'autre ou la situation
financière est catastrophique que je ne
vois pas comment vous annoncez 10
millions d'euros d'investissements sans
augmenter les impôts ou la situation
financière est plus équilibrée que celle
que vous mentionnez est en effet nous
pouvons investir aux alentours de 8
millions d'euros par an j'avance jeudi
le patron revenir viendra peut-être mais
pour que l'île est nommé pascal dufresne
puisse exprimer vous allez commencer par
les impôts ghislaine launay tout à
l'heure dans votre propos introductif
parce que vous vous êtes toujours sur la
même ligne pas d'augmentation des impôts
si non mais je ne sais pas
vous trouvez vos chiffres moi je vois
donnez votre micro devant votre mieux je
vois en 2012 il y a eu des transferts de
chalon sur l'agglomération qui était
jusque-là à peu près en équilibre on se
retrouve entre les camps 2007 c'était à
peu près en équilibre et on se retrouve
en 2012 avec des dépenses de personnel
qui ont qui ont grandi de 2,7 pour
qu'ils en tirent augmenté de près de 3
fois il y avait 9 millions + 2 9
millions en 2007
là on en est à 27 millions la dette sur
le grand chalon est passé de plus de 22
millions à 62 millions je ne sais pas
ces chiffres sont issus de la chambre
régionale des comptes dont je ne vois
pas où vous vous trouvez à une
amélioration de la situation
quand j'ai juste à montrer aux factures
c'est chez pascal dufresne quand même
parce qu'il y avait but it est donc
formé il ya deux éléments qui paraissent
extraordinaires
bien évidemment madame que lorsque l'on
transfère les compétences qu'on
transfère aussi les personnels donc il
est assez logique que les personnels qui
étaient avant des personnels villes
deviennent des personnels grand chalon
et voudriez vous devriez vous devriez
d'ailleurs puisque vous prétendez
défendre les contribuables chalonnais
plutôt considérer que c'est une bonne
chose que nous ayons enfin nous fait
partager des charges de centralité c'est
à dire des choses qui jusqu'àlors était
utilisé par tout le monde mais payée
exclusivement par les contribuables de
chalonnais que nous les ayons fait
partagé par l'ensemble des contribuables
du grand chalon sur la dette du grand
chalon alors de ce point de vue là
également je rappelle quelques éléments
de transfert de compétences ce n'est pas
simplement la ville de chalon qui a
transféré des compétences au grand
chalon c'est l'ensemble des 39 communes
de l'époque qui ont transféré des
compétences donc comparer l'endettement
du grand chalon avec l'endettement de la
ville
c'est ignorer 38 autres communes qui
notamment sur des enjeux aussi fort que
l'eau l'assainissement ont transféré des
emprunts donc un moment il faut creuser
un peu les dossiers les connaître avant
que de n'afficher que des chiffres qui
ne correspondent pas à la réalité de la
situation parce qu'elle dufrègne un mot
sur la dimension sociale le ras-le-bol
fiscale la difficulté pour les gens j
justement je n'entends pas le même
discours dans les quartiers encore une
fois parce que les travailleurs eux ils
ont le sentiment de payer de plus en
plus toujours plus que ce soit sur les
impôts locaux
les impôts sur le revenu les loyers qui
augmentent l'électricité la tva est
l'impôt le plus injuste qui frappe le
riche et le pauvre la même façon tous
ces éléments-là s'orchestrer pas
forcément localement et orchestrée par
le gouvernement socialiste
comme je le disais tout à l'heure pour
arroser à coups de milliards les patrons
et faire payer la dette et la crise aux
travailleurs a effectivement moi je
pense que si on continue à chercher des
solutions budgétaires a causé à
s'engueuler sur tel budget là-dessus
derrière toutes ces dettes de la mairie
c'est des cadeaux aux entreprises
locales ou à des entreprises plus grosse
c'est la même politique qui est faite
nationale manqué reprise localement et
moi je me dis que si on veut s'en sortir
nous les ouvriers
si on veut arrêter de payer il faudra
bien qu'on trouve une solution pour
faire payer la bourgeoisie alors vous
avez prononcé un mot vous parlez de
cadeaux aux entreprises et ça peut nous
amener au moins sur ce qu'on avait prévu
de parler pour la suite un mot si vous
le permettez juste sur la question vous
arrêterez 20 sur la question
d'investissements pour pas à me
mobiliser
on n'était pas sur les aspects
complémentaires dont j'entends bien
qu'ils sont un peu aride mais quand on a
des périmètres de chiffres qui changent
à chaque discours
évidemment c'est un peu difficile pour
les citoyens de se repérer nous avons
dit que nous souhaitions geler
l'évolution des taux parce qu'ils ont
augmenté trop vite et trop fort dans la
durée du mandat et que continuer
d'augmenter les taux d'imposition s'est
fait peur de l'attractivité à notre
territoire
on a aussi des problèmes démographiques
qui sont liées en partie soit que les
gens aient quitté ce territoire soit
qu'ils aient du mal à y investir parce
que la pression fiscale est très forte
sur la question des investissements
nous avons chiffré dans notre projet
tous pour chalon un niveau raisonnable à
10 millions d'euros par an dans le
précédent mandat
la moyenne était de 13 millions d'euros
par an ça n'est pas moi qui lis est
reconnue nous partageons ce constat
puisque ça a été annoncé comme un
élément de votre bilan par vous même
mais là où nous sommes évidemment dans
une optique différente
nous nous ne détruisons pas de notre
niveau d'investissement
les subventions reçues
monsieur sirugue fait une soustraction
ce qui est incroyable en matière
budgétaire ça n'existe pas il nous dit
je vais faire 7 8 millions d'euros
d'investissements en déduisant les aides
que je recevrai ou met vraiment en duvet
dans votre progrès ou avec notre nom
alors je vous demande de me montrer à
quel point votre prono de moins qu'en
l'occurrence on s'étonne si vous me
permettez endroit ne vous énervez
permission les suppressions les
énervements rêver c'est à quel endroit
où le débat quel endroit donc on est
grosso modo je pense si on rajoute les
trois millions cinq de subventions en
moyenne qu'on a touché un investissement
sûr ce mandat sur le même niveau mais la
différence supplémentaire c'est que nous
avons élaboré un plan d'économies en
matière de fonctionnement sans toucher
aux services publics sans toucher aux
services publics qui nous permet d'avoir
des perspectives de dégagement
d'économies de l'ordre d'un million
d'euros et évidemment on sait très bien
que nous ne sommes plus à l'ère des
grandes promesses
nous sommes à l'ère de l'amélioration du
quotidien des gens et c'est ça la base
de notre projet alors il sait pourquoi
nous parviendrons à l'homme juste un mot
on se met d'accord christophe sirugue
répond là dessus et on passe au chalet
de beauregard m'attendais à un moment je
ne peux pas laisser dire des choses ne
sont pas dans le projet il a été
distribué à tous les habitants c'était
facile à vérifier cela étant nous nous
avons inscrit 10,8 millions d'euros
d'investissements dans le budget 2014
10,8 millions d'euros nous considérons
que pour les années qui viennent il faut
descendre à 8 millions d'euros
nonobstant la question des subventions
n'a jamais inscrit des investissements
tenant compte des subventions d'ailleurs
ce serait très imprudent
à l'époque où on sait que les
subventions risque de baisser donc on
est bien car vous vous inscrivez 10
c'est ce que vous avez écrit dans votre
projet très bien deuxième élément sur
lequel je voudrais revenir les économies
que vous annoncez un million d'euros
j'ai vu dans votre document allez vous
de l'été dedans on va gagner sur les
indemnités d'élu je vous rappelle que
c'est nous qui avons baissé dès 2008 les
indemnités des élus alors qu'on ne nous
mettons pas obligé je vous rappelle que
un maire à plein temps coûtera forcément
beaucoup plus cher que moi même puisque
je suis écrêté je le rappelle je suis
écrié vous laisserai pas dire je leur
aie je suis et crée t on parlera je me
lève le matin
le monde sait qu'un parlementaire et
écrêté chez son rôle sur le lancer le
débat la ville car je pense que ce
serait la cause est éloigné des réalités
quotidiennes des gens les putschistes
ont des touches sur le rich des sommes
comme les veaux comme on notera que je
vous ai piqué le savent pas je vais
reconnaître encore dans le quotidien les
autres économies on nous l'a ceci sur
les autres économies on nous parle du
journal municipal je voudrais quand même
rappeler que nous avons fait nous en
faisant travailler ensemble journal du
grand chalon le journal municipal en les
distribuant même temps nous avons fait
une économie de 210 mille euros dessus
vous avez beau travailler sur les
indemnités vous aurez beau travailler
sur ces éléments là vous ne ferez pas un
million d'euros d'économies vous les
ferez vous les frais si vous supprimez
des services assure est ce que vous ne
voulez pas dire c'est comment vous
faites pour dans une situation
financière catastrophique sans augmenter
les impôts
en ayant 10 millions d'euros
d'investissement comment vous faites
pour boucler le budget si vous ne
diminuait pas les services publics vous
mentez aux chalonnais sur ce point de
vue là parce que vous avez en tête
d'ailleurs j'ai vu sur la page facebook
de l'un de vos colistiers monsieur
guigue tout le bien qu'il pensait du
personnel municipal avec une vidéo qui
l'a diffusée dans lesquelles il se
plaint du bruit des personnels qui
nettoie la rue le matin à 5 heures après
le fils de carnaval si c'est ça l'image
que vous aviez les services publics on a
du travail
je me permets de vous couper parce que
sinon on parlera pas non plus de la
circulation de se dire quelque chose de
grave je me lève révélant des vins vers
le personnel municipal aujourd'hui et
maltraités dans cette collectivité en
trois mois deux tentatives de suicide
monsieur sirugue parce que votre
directeur général des services en votre
nom mène une politique de ressources
humaines inadaptée f est vraiment
monsieur des désagréables son lanceur
des majeures et vous venez je reçois
dans mon bureau personnel quand ils
viennent qui sont à genoux la radio
était manager de castanet dur il ne
connaît pas la seynoise il nous reste
deux personnes accueillies si monsieur
platret quand on ne connaît pas la
situation personnelle des deux personnes
que je la connais sionistes sont les
avoir engagé la lettre g la lettre
qu'une des personnes envoyées viviani
ment pas la diffuser une des deux qui a
vu les difficultés vous mentionnez et
qui difficultés particulièrement sur son
lieu d elle
dans cette lettre ce comment elle a été
particulièrement bien reçu par directeur
général des services donc ne dit pas l'
inverse au risque et facal temps sur les
agents sur les agents qu'on avance la
déprécarisation c'est nous la mise en
place du régime indemnitaire
c'est nous le travail sur les avantages
sociaux c'est nous et je rappelle que
quand je suis arrivé il y avait une
lettre de la préfecture parce que celle
là y en avait une qui dénonçait la
précarité des personnels qui avaient été
faites par la majorité trop qu'on avance
nous reste nous reste 5 minutes
ça s'appelle une politique de
clientélisme c'est défendre dans des
madame vous avez irréel si vous aspirez
vous aspirez à être maire de chalon sur
saône et vous ne vous préoccupez par les
agents bien de la collectivité mais bien
c'est du clientélisme du coup de
s'occuper sont honnêtes employeurs à
seulement non seulement bien évident au
reste il nous reste 12 minutes avant les
informations midi on a passé beaucoup de
temps sur la partie fiscale
on croit comprendre télé important dans
cette dans cette campagne on avait prévu
de parler à la fois de l'attractivité
des entreprises mais aussi de la vie
quotidienne des chalonnais de la
circulation
moi je voudrais quand même peut-être
qu'on avance et et qu'on se pose la
question effectivement de la vie
quotidienne des chalonnais parce qu'il
semble que ce soit important dans cette
campagne aussi on parle beaucoup à
chalon de transport de bus venant de
circulation c'est vrai qu'il ya la
question la question de ce qu'on appelle
le flash c'est le bus de chalon et du
plan de circulation qui est lié j'ai
envie de poser la question à à ghislaine
launay qui finalement la seule candidate
qui n'habitent pas chalon avez vous eu
du mal à vous garer puisqu'il paraît que
c'est très compliqué à chalon deux gares
et de circuler à certaines heures
aujourd'hui samedi matin pas trop mais
lorsque je viens pour faire mes courses
dans dans chalon même j'avoue que je
tourne beaucoup et que je pense que pour
venir de la place de beaune a
la gare il vaut mieux venir à pied parce
que la circulation est insupportable on
fait des détours on laisse la place face
et c'est effectivement très difficile de
se retrouver dans le dans le centre de
chalon vraiment je le vis à chaque fois
que je viens et c'est extrêmement
dissuasif pour toutes les personnes qui
viennent pour faire leurs courses à
chalon et qui du coup vont aller front
se diriger dans la périphérie et vont
aller alimenter ses grandes zones
commerciales qui ne profite qu'à des
grands groupes et pas et pas vraiment là
les commerces à chalon il ya 38 30 % de
baisse sur ces dernières années et léon
il faut voir les boutiques fermées c
'est c'est extrêmement grave parce que
vous je ne sais pas il va tout d'abord
revenir sur la question précédente
parce que le développement de l'an
territoire c'est un des grands sujets
que j'ai pu lire dans les plaquettes des
deux candidats et pour moi c'est encore
la même politique qui va consister que
ce soit l'un qu'ils soient élus ou que
ce soit l'autre a donné l'argent public
à toutes ces entreprises locales et
nationales ça sera toujours la même
politique qu'au niveau national
continuer à arroser les patrons à leur
donner l'argent public est derrière tout
le monde le sait que sacré parvenir
amazon par exemple tout le monde le sait
que ça crée pas un emploi amazon 7 en
concurrence entre beaune et ici ou c'est
moi juin de kodak un kodak qu'ils ont
sous touche énormément de subventions
pour revenir d'ici pige été licenciés et
puis un ado qui a deux fours à saint
gobain qui ont été payés par l'ancienne
mairie et on n'arrête pas et ben moi je
dis qu'il y en a marre de samar de cette
politique qui va être mise en oeuvre
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement
socialiste est relayée par christophe
sirugue à chalon et demain peut-être par
gilles platret y en a marre de ça ça ne
marche pas ses solutions là alors on
avance aussi sur notre sujet un des
choix qui a été fait à chalon sur la
particulier sur la circulation et sur
l'aménagement c'est le choix d'un bus à
haut niveau de haut niveau de rendement
et de vitesse qui qui s'adresse aussi
aux catégories populaires qui n'ont pas
forcément la possibilité de se déplacer
est ce que de votre point de vue dans le
positionnement vous allez politiquement
dans ce débat ça vous semble important
je suis ni juste avant excuses à bas
on s'en va on vous laisse vous laisse je
pense effectivement il ya beaucoup de
blabla là dedans et que pour lutter
contre le chômage puisque l'on parle
d'emploi il faudrait peut-être déjà à
commencer par l'interdire c'est pour ça
que lutte ouvrière on met en avant une
mesure qui devrait imposer par les
luttes des travailleurs c'est
l'interdiction des licenciements ça les
autres candidats ne le disent pas et
tant qu'ils ne diront pas qu'avant pour
lutter pour l'emploi il faut déjà
l'interdire il faut déjà empêché les
patrons de nuire il faut déjà empêché
l'hémorragie ça c'est ce que je voulais
conclure et pour revenir sur la
circulation
effectivement vous savez moi je
travaille à la sncf et on le voit que ça
se dégrade tous les transports on voit
que ça se dégrade de transport public
on voit que les services publics se
dégradent pourquoi est là parce
qu'encore une fois il faut payer cette
dette au niveau de l'état et impose aux
villes des restrictions dans tous les
domaines l'état l'hôpital de chalon il
ya de moins en moins d'effectifs
pourquoi on n'en parle pas assez des
problèmes nationaux les vrais problèmes
des travailleurs de cette ville ne sont
que des problèmes nationaux ya rien de
local dans les problèmes essentiels des
travailleurs et ça il faut bien le dire
gilles platret circulation vous avez
beaucoup insisté dans l'avant campagne
on va dire sur les accidents la
circulation on a une vraie problématique
liée à la circulation dans cette ville
on est parti je pense de sentiments qui
pouvait être louable et notamment la
diversification et l'augmentation de
l'offre de transport en commun personne
est opposée à la au développement des
transports en commun parce qu'on peut
sur ce plan-là trouver un consensus mais
nous sommes évidemment en opposition
directe avec ce qui a été fait parce que
sur certains secteurs de la ville on n'a
pas joué la complémentarité des offres
de transport on a joué le bus contre la
voiture et c'est bien ce que nous
regrettons le flash aujourd'hui est à 1
est un objet qui de discorde sur la
scène politique chalonnaise mais il
suffit d'écouter les chalonnais n'a rien
inventé
il suffit de les interroger sur leurs
difficultés d'accéder au centre-ville
la première la deuxième couronne mais
les chalonnais dans les quartiers ont du
mal à venir également lorsqu'ils veulent
venir faire leurs courses
donc sauf s'ils prennent le bus mais
tout le monde ne prend pas le but s'il
ya encore des voitures
dans ce pays je pense que la voiture
contrairement à ce qu'on nous dit à un
avenir devant elle ces modes de
consommation ne viendront sans doute de
plus en plus vert mais elle existe et
aujourd'hui on va pas demander aux
ménages de se séparer de leur voiture
donc on a aujourd'hui une vraie
problématique circulation sur chalon sur
saône qui est une problématique qui a
qui finalement interroge et
l'attractivité de la ville
quand vous ne pouvez plus avoir une
circulation fluide sur votre centre
ville quand vous avez des axes qui sont
essentiellement accidentogène je pense à
la rocade parce qu'on a fait des
expérimentations dont on n'a pas voulu
reconnaître l'erreur à m'ont donné ce
qui précipite le nombre d'accidents sur
cet axe quand vous avez des commerces
qui depuis la mise en place de cette
ligne de bus à haut niveau de service
connaissent des chiffres d'affaires des
baisses de chiffre d'affaires de l'ordre
de 25 30 40 % alors oui il y apprendre
les circulations est ce que nous
proposons saleh une fois le constat fait
c'est de travailler dans les six mois
qui suivent l'élection à la
fluidification des grands axes qui pose
le plus problème dans cette ville
respire une des questions est ce qu'il y
a des problèmes de circulation à chalon
et pourquoi avez vous renoncé à la ligne
2 du flash qui devait faire sans marcel
champforgeuil alors d'abord comme toutes
les villes on s'est interrogé sur les
nouveaux équilibres qui doivent exister
entre les transports en commun la
voiture les piétons les vélos
comme toutes les villes on a essayé de
trouver le meilleur système
les grandes fondé mettez des métros les
grandes font des tramways nous nous
avons bien évidemment pris le principe
d'un bus est-ce que cela perturbe les
habitudes de déplacement
bien évidemment je rappelle que le plan
de circulation de chalon datait de 1962
et que depuis il y avait eu des
évolutions ne serait-ce qu'en nombre de
voitures dans la ville est ce que on
veut évacuer la voiture mais pas du tout
on veut simplement rééquilibrer les
choses
alors est ce qu'il y a encore des
difficultés de circulation oui nous
avons et je les ai déjà dit quelques
points sur lesquels il nous faut
continuer à travailler d'ailleurs les
services continuent à travailler
aujourd'hui la rocade entre ce qu'elle a
été lorsque nous l'avons transformé
aujourd'hui il n'y a à l'évidence
aujourd'hui beaucoup moins de
difficultés ne dis pas qu'il n'y en a
pas on a un carrefour qui mérite d'être
regardée de près qui est celui de
l'avenue de paris et de la rocade
mais pour le reste là
dit et il est aujourd'hui et c'est
d'ailleurs le commissaire de police qui
le déclarait il n'y a pas si longtemps
que cela mais nous continuons à voir des
endroits où il y à des concentrations
vers la place de beaune de difficulté
vers la place de beaune vers le secteur
de la colombière et les services
continue à travailler là dessus
est ce que pour autant il faut remettre
en cause le flash que monsieur platret
n'a jamais voté
donc quand il dit on est d'accord c'est
pas vrai n'a jamais voté le flash quand
nous l'avons mis en place sur cette
ligne il y avait trois mille deux cents
voyageurs jour il y en a cinq mille sept
cents aujourd'hui que ça veut dire que
ça a bien trouvé son public et qu'il ya
peut-être des gens qu'ils n'utiliseront
jamais le bus en tout cas ils le pensent
aujourd'hui
et puis d'autres pour qu'ils nous avons
besoin de développer ses traits vous
avait enterré le projet numéro deux
alors sur le projet numéro 2 nous avons
inscrit une étude
l'étude nous montre aujourd'hui qu'entre
le le trajet c'est à dire où la vie des
deux puits champforgeuil jusqu'à saint
marcel et le gain potentiel
le gain potentiel de clients nouveaux
sur la ligne il semble déraisonnable
d'inscrire cet élément là donc je les
dis mais je ne les ai pas dit
dernièrement je les dis déjà depuis
plusieurs semaines je les ai même dit à
la première réunion publique que j'ai
fait c'était le 13 février à boucicaut
nous ne ferons pas flash 2 mais nous
continuerons à améliorer le réseau de
transports en commun parce que nous en
avons véritablement besoin et nous avons
besoin de l'étoffé gilles platret qu'est
ce que vous voulez changer sur ce flash
il existe il est là le flash et là on va
pas revendre les machines on veut
simplement que on arrête de jouer le bus
contre la voiture ça veut dire que pour
les secteurs où il ya une difficulté il
faudra que la voiture puisse reprendre
un peu plus de place par rapport au bus
ce qui veut évidemment bien dire que le
bus est conservé maintenant j'aimerais
quand même revenir sur cette question du
flash 2 le conseil communautaire du 20
juin de l'année dernière a voté une
délibération dans laquelle il est dit
dans la continuité de sa politique de
déplacement et fort du succès du flash
le grand chalon souhaite réaliser une
seconde ligne donc je veux bien que le
thème étant essentiellement impopulaire
aujourd'hui on nous dise sans qu'il y
ait eu aucune délibération du grand
chalon d'ailleurs pour entériner cette
position qu'on nous dise aujourd'hui que
la ligne est enterré
simplement je voudrais aussi qu'on ne
touche pas aux conditions de circulation
sur le pont jean richard
et vous savez très bien que cette
affaire est encore à l'étude aujourd'hui
donc ce que nous souhaitons nous l'avons
dit dès le départ il n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté
il n'y aura pas de ligne numéro 2 nous
adapterons la ligne numéro un pour
qu'elle ne soit pas en obstruction
frontale avec la circulation automobile
de sorte que nous puissions fluidifier
la circulation sur le centre et
permettent de donner un signal fort à
l'extérieur pour que les gens puissent
revenir
il ya des places de stationnement dans
la ville il y en a qui sont
sous-exploitées en souterrain on a aussi
quelques projets en matière de
signalétique de fléchage et
d'indications aux entrées de ville en
temps réel du nombre de places
disponibles dans les parkings de la
ville
il faudra évidemment repenser les
relations avec la société q park
si on veut que les tarifs soient plus
attractifs mais en le en l'état actuel
des choses la nécessité absolue
c'est agir vite et bien sûr cette
affaire parce qu'il il en va de
l'attractivité de touche à l'autre parce
que les fruits très serré que juste très
beau il nous reste une minute démission
juste quand on parle de tout ça derrière
ça va être des choses nouvelles
construites dont des impôts nouveaux
pour les chalonnais ça va être des
choses à payer et on parle surtout pas
et ça personne n'en parle personne ne le
dit que tous ces contrats cds marché
juteux pour les entreprises locales ou
les entreprises publiques et il faudra
bien nous après on les paye nous les
ouvriers et on nous demande pas notre
avis là dessus c'est du frais et les
contrats c'est aussi des emplois ne
l'oublions pas on parle pas forcément
cet accord activités pour une fois
l'activité récente
ça c'est du baratin c'est du passé de
concret les mêmes solutions sont
employés par la droite et la gauche
depuis 30 ans c'est toujours de nous
dire qu'en faisant ce genre de choses ça
va créer de l'emploi us avaient marre
d'être actif
c'est quand même le meilleur moyen cette
journée en vidéo
parlons du pont jean richard dans votre
journal vous proposiez de faire le pont
jean richard dans un sens et le pont
saint laurent dans l'autre c'est vous
qui le président n'est pas nouveau
c'était ça
nations là vous l'avez écrit les six sur
un couloir des vous l'avez écrit genre
ici sans quoi vous portez vous l'avez
vous vous avez fait beaucoup pour
prendre ce journal 2010 messieurs s'il
vous plaît à la seconde on va se faire
disputer par la rédaction de dijon c'est
l'heure du journal on se retrouve juste
après